so basically how han ended up in fast
and furious was
um it was it was justin lin
you know he had the opportunity to go
direct uh tokyo drift
and he had called a few of the actors
from better luck tomorrow just to have
lunch
and you know he explained to us he's
like hey you know i
understand how rare these opportunities
come you know there are very few roles
for you out there
and i just wanted to tell you you know
i'm directing this big fast and furious
movie for universal
but none of you are going to be cast in
the film
because none of you fit right and
because at that time there was no han in
the film
right and there was a smaller character
in the original script that had a quick
scene
with sean boswell he gives him the keys
and i think i think his name was phoenix
and at that time there you know the idea
was to cast
an african-american like hip-hop star
you know some musician to do a cameo for
that
but bow was already cast and
you know justin had this conversation
with the studio saying you know
why is it that with this other character
you know why does
he have to be like asian specific
why can't they just be a guy that
represents something and
they're i think they ask like what like
what does he represent you know
somebody cool somebody inclusive
somebody you want to hang out with
and justin showed better luck tomorrow
to everybody and they
understood what he was talking about and
the rest was history you know
i was barely in the script it was me and
justin
you know every day kind of you know
going over
you know his character arc and him
finding places to
kind of put him into the story and i was
walking around with a bunch of snacks
because you know i did not want to carry
the smoking habit from better luck
tomorrow
into a fast and furious movie because i
knew how many kids were gonna watch this
film
and i know you know if you see somebody
up there
looking cool smoking cigarettes you know
you are
gonna probably you know mimic that you
know especially as a young person
and so i watched some films uh like
magnificent seven with steve mcqueen
and brad pitt from snatch and i noticed
they're
always eating and i was like oh that's
just a great
kind of you know character kind of you
know
like habit for me because i'm always
observing you know i
had very few lines that i was actually
saying and so
you know when you're watching something
watching a movie you're snacking
and so that's where the whole snacking
thing kind of came and i remember
i had this bag big old family pack of
snacks i was kidding around on set every
day and
where one of the producers grabbed the
snacks and it's like what's with you and
the snacks
and then when the movie came out he goes
oh okay now i understand what you were
doing
he's got his own private army we need
help
no way
so how do y'all want to play this fast
so when i started in better luck
tomorrow with han
you know the idea of playing a
california
you know southern cali asian american
guy
was so you know unfamiliar to me because
you know the guys in la or southern cali
they just have a different swagger about
them you know they have a different
cadence
compared to the way i grew up i grew up
in the south in georgia
so it was smaller community you know
it's
much more conservative and you know the
guys out there we just didn't have the
same
uh you know swagger or cadence about us
and i had to go and hang out with some
l.a born or you know
southern cali like you know dudes out
here to figure out where they get their
chip on their shoulders because there is
a kind of a
bravado about them there's this like
hyper masculine kind of
you know tough guy persona and they
don't see themselves
as like a you know marginalized like
community you know they see it
themselves as an alpha and i
that was really intriguing and as an
actor to go you know where do you get
this confidence and where do you get
this swagger
and you know working with justin i use
the
comparison of a nba basketball coach you
know
you know he has his plan of attack but
he knows where your strengths or
weaknesses are
and then he comes in and he helps you
with that right and
we were able to really kind of dissect
what han was about
that you know he's a little different
from the other kids
you know within the better luck tomorrow
movie because he's probably
you know more from a blue collar
background
and the reason he even has that 65
mustang is
you know his father was is probably a
mechanic
you know in k-town or some you know part
of l.a you know
and um and that's where you know han
learned his love affair for cars right
that's where he
learned his way around you know you know
under the hood
uh but then you know it was that swagger
it was that confidence you know it's
like even the question of like why did
this guy smoke so much
because i was in a smoker you know at
that time and i was like what are these
guys always smoking they look
they always look so pensive you know so
you know you you hang out
you know it was a great opportunity to
kind of get in the skin of these guys in
la and you know play like a hyper
masculine dude
it's good to be back well the first time
i found out
or was aware of the hashtag justice for
han
was from jan yamato currently at the la
times you know i didn't know her at the
time
you know i think we ran into each other
a few times at some events but i didn't
i didn't know her
and so there was no personal connection
so i knew
you know she wasn't trying to help a
friend out or you know it had nothing to
do with you know being biased towards me
and you know i wanted i was like who is
this person is she just like a fangirl
like freaking out
but there was like reason behind it
because something was unsettling
you know in her stomach about the demise
or the exit of han from this massive
franchise you know
that's a different conversation but you
know
you know she there was sincerity in what
she was doing it wasn't just like a
crazy fan
and so it made me go into this rabbit
hole and
you know go and reach out to her and to
kind of really study like
where and why is this coming from and
it's really humbling
you know it's humbling when people want
you back and they're excited to see you
you know they mention your name and
you know as an actor it's super
flattering you know it's like it
legitimizes your existence
you know and i have to go back and i
have to thank jen
and i have to thank all the fans for
really pushing that hashtag because
i think that's the majority of the you
know the major reason why han is back
we supposed to stop that hold on
when you first get recognized in public
for playing a role
you know it's a little jarring and it
becomes about self
you know it's like hey i'm special now
like everybody wants my picture and you
know they want to invite me to their
parties
and then you step back and you go well
what does it all mean it's like after
the party's over and then so what
you know and there was a time where i
started
kind of questioning the whole idea of
being famous for one character and i was
like what's the point of that i
don't think i want to be that and i knew
the impact of
of han and fast and furious when this
situation happened
i'd gone back home to georgia to go see
some relatives and
um we went fishing and we're driving
through alabama
and to go to florida and uh i was with
two cousins two guys um and a friend so
there were like four you know asian
dudes in this truck driving through
alabama to go to florida
and one other cousin is a little
paranoid and he said hey you know i know
you got a mouth on you
and don't stop at this gas station and
talk whole bunch of nonsense to people
especially if someone says something to
you
that's derogatory here because hey you
know we are in the deep south and i'm
like
okay whatever and we get out and i go
into the gas station
and you know there's a young man there
and you know he's kind of talking to
a couple of customers and i'm i'm a
little you know pensive there and i'm
you know i'm a little concerned like
what this guy is going to say or what
energy he's going to project
and he looks up and his eyes kind of
bulge and he goes
oh my god his hand his hand
he goes wait right here he starts to
call his mom he's like mama hands here
he's like who han
and from fast and furious toby jeff he's
here he's here
and never did he mention it's the asian
guy or it's the oriental guy it's the
chinese guy it's hand
it's hand it's my front hand and
my cousins are like freaking out they're
like they had never witnessed that and i
was going whoa there's nothing
confrontational here there's nothing
negative
there's nothing divisive it was a guy
who felt like he grew up with me
right a guy that wanted to invite me
into his garage and show me his car and
crack open the beer and share his like
story
right and that's when i realized man you
know
this is way bigger than me right and
then to see my
the reactions of my family members and
my cousins in the car
you know driving they're like you know
they're like hey we never thought
you know you being an actor was gonna
impact the world this way because you
know we grew up being bullied you know
it's just the way it was because we were
you know we're a bunch of nobodies in
the small town so we were used to that
we're being used to being marginalized
never
having a voice and for my cousins to say
that to go
a character that you play in the fast
and furious movie in their words is
it's gotten rid of racism to a degree
within
within this village station there's no
racism and
you could everyone's just smiling on
their way to florida you know
and i i hope that it kind of explains
what han
means to me right and how it's it i see
it transcending throughout the world
especially today with all this
divisiveness
i think every character in fast nine
represents some a degree of that
you know
not today
you